hey guys i'm miranda cosgrove and i play
carly shea i'm jerry traynor i play
spencer shea i'm nathan cress i play
freddie benson and we're here with
buzzfeed and we're gonna find out which
icarly character we all are in real life
in real life it might surprise you
first question how would your best
friends describe you passionate
loyal cunning one-of-a-kind creative or
cool as heck
definitely not cool as heck um you have
your moments
thank you nathan i'm gonna go with loyal
that was the way that i was gonna go too
i would hope that my friends would think
that i'm loyal so at this point we might
end up being the same person i don't
know that's so exciting but i'm gonna
i'm gonna say loyal too because i am
certainly not cool as heck trademark
i don't think any of my friends would
say cool as heck with a straight face
i'm gonna say they're gonna say one of a
kind i would pick that one for you i
agree with that that's 100
only jerry trainer is jerry traynor
that's right next question pick an
iconic icarly guest star the choices are
jack black
one direction harry shum jr michelle
obama emily ratajkowski and jordan
fisher i mean i'm picking jack black
i'm picking jack black too that's pretty
classic i'm gonna go michelle obama
about some history right there
next question pick an even more iconic
icarly villain
we got chuck with his super soaker
lubert
neville paperman mr howard missy or
mandy valdez mandy was so funny
oh my god oh i don't know i'm feeling
i'm feeling chuck he messed spencer up
big time and then he got his little
brother involved too it was like a crime
family
i went with neville i'm going luber all
good choices
iconic episode of icarly i saved your
life
i got a hot room i party with victorious
i date a bad boy
i go one direction or i got detention
hard those are all
iconic i got a hot room is where you get
your new room my party was victorious
was the big crossover with keenan one
direction had one direction i did a bad
boy
was where miranda starts making that
with the bad boy
ow scream at the top of your lungs for a
straight minute i'm gonna pick i date a
bad boy i think i'm gonna go
i saved your life because it started
that whole series of questions
that people are still asking that's true
what the yuck miranda and nathan both
picked i saved your life huh
interesting buzzfeed if you had your own
digital web series
what kind of content would you post
makeup tutorials
diy projects health and fitness
conspiracy theories
cooking or asmr i would do conspiracy
theories
fast tracks oh i'm picking asmr yeah 100
you're asmr
i think i'm diy projects not because i'd
be good at them but because i want to
try to get good at them by having people
who know what they're doing on with me
to teach me how to
do things and and be a decently
effective
man that's how everyone on set refers to
you as a decently effective man
that's all i want is nathan here is he
being decently effective today
as a male miranda do you believe in uh
ufos and aliens
yes do you share carly's belief in
bigfoot
i'm not as passionate about bigfoot as
carly
but i wouldn't mind going on a trip in
an rv with you guys to look for bigfoot
that'd be pretty fun dude that'd
actually be a good time
which snack from the icarly cinematic
universe sounds
the tastiest fat cakes a groovy smoothie
smoothie
spaghetti tacos gallini's coconut cream
pie
anything from the cheesecake warehouse
or anything on a stick
see if i pick spaghetti tacos i'm going
to get spencer and i don't want to be me
you want to get something different i
want to get something different i'm
gonna say
anything on a stick just because that
sounds so bizarre even though i love
spaghetti tacos and i've had a smoothie
from the groovy smoothie and they're
very good i love coconut cream pie it
just sounds too good
i'm gonna say anything from the
cheesecake warehouse
mostly just because the portions were
just one
third a bowl of salad that's in like a
two gallon mixing bowl
it's a 20 000 calorie salad so that that
sounds pretty powerful to me i'm going
with the cheesecake warehouse
pick a nickelodeon show to get rebooted
next
oh choices are big time rush
victorious doug ned's declassified
school survival guide truejacksonvp
and clarissa explains it all how could
they do this
i mean i loved doug as a kid i'm leaning
towards i think the world needs some big
time rush
i watched every episode of ned's
declassified i think i'm going with
ned's as well
that was one of my go-to shows back in
the day
[Music]
oh my god i can't believe who i got what
did you get
i got sam really you did here's what it
says sam puckett
you're one tough nugget puckett
if you ever need backup people are gonna
want you and your butter stick
in their corner butter stick to butter
sock buzzfeed
well there is a stick of butter in the
sock oh that's true a stick of butter in
the
got it you know what i think i got who i
actually am in real life there you go
okay who'd you get miranda i got you
really vinson it says you're the smart
whiz kid everyone wants on their team
and their friend group
plus you're not too hard on the eyes
either
things have changed well i got i got me
too i guess you and i are just very much
on the same page
we're both ready we're we're gonna all
want to retake it and try and get myself
what is the spencer description you just
want to hear it say you're easy on the
eyes
better say i'm easy on the eyes dude now
i understand why we connect so much on
such a deeply personal level i know it's
because we were the same character all
along
i love that i'm like the guy you call
when you need backup
that's a good perk to be it makes me
feel good half the time i
am just being freddie in my daily life
so the fact that a buzzfeed quiz proves
it
validates everything that i know about
my identity i've always eschewed
astrology that the buzzfeed quiz has
really changed
things thank you for having us buzzfeed
please
check out icarly on paramount plus thank
you buzzfeed
bye thank you thanks for your quizzes i
do them all the time
[Music]
[Music]
you